did Robin make an appearance in the
Batman without anyone noticing well yes
and no keep watching to find out how the
Boy Wonder appeared alongside Robert
Pattinson's Dark Knight and the Batman
after long production delays due to
covid-19 the Batman is finally here the
latest story told on screen featuring
one of DC Comics most famous characters
is helmed by director Mata Reeves
previously known for his work on Dawn of
the Planet of the Apes War for the
planets of the apes and Cloverfield
after Ben Affleck decided to step away
from playing the Caped Crusader Reeve
stepped up to tell a new Batman story
with Pattinson the Batman also features
a plot with the main antagonist being
the Riddler played by Paul Dano a
character we haven't seen in live action
since Corey Michael Smith played the
role on Gotham before that there was
1995's Batman Forever with Jim Carrey
playing a highly charismatic obsessive
and very campy version of the classic
Batman villain Dano's version is
incredibly dark violent and vengeful
although both Batman Forever and the
Batman feature The Riddler as one of
their main antagonists they were pretty
vast and obvious differences between
both films for one there is a massively
important character missing from the
Batman that was featured in 1995. Robin
although nothing is really ever hinted
about Dick Grayson or Robin during the
Batman an actor who had previously
played one of the Robins in live action
appeared very early on in the movie and
you might have missed him in his big
scene more the opening to the Batman
starts off by introducing us to a very
demented and creepy Riddler it isn't
long before moviegoers are hit with a
narration from Robert Pattinson's Bruce
Wayne it's Halloween nights and Gotham
City is celebrating but as Bruce notes
crime still runs rampant Gotham City
Police Department Lieutenant James
Gordon played by Jeffrey Wright lights
up the bat signal and we see common
criminals on the streets start to get
scared feeling fearful that somewhere
nearby Batman could be hiding in the
shadows the film comes to the subway
where a few face-painted men are
huddling around watching a video they
took of themselves assaulting someone
for fun although the youngest in the
group seems to be uncomfortable with it
without much dialogue the youngest is
told by the leader of the group to
pursue and attack another person on the
subway with them and as they do they're
confronted by Batman as seen in the
first trailer for the film Batman beats
the leader and utters an iconic line
that plays an important role throughout
the actual film I'm vengeance the rest
of the group except for the young kid
proceed to attack about man and fail he
and Batman share a look where the kid
scene simultaneously relieved that
Batman showed up and also Amazed by what
he sees and then he runs off this kid
happens to be played by actor Jay like
Ergo in the credits the kid is referred
to Simply as train gang young member but
he actually plays a character who's
known as DC Comics Robin in another
project if you're a DC fan you probably
saw Jay lukergo playing Tim Drake in
season 3 of Titans before his quick part
in the Batman the HBO mag show actually
sends us around being Robin in general
as the first season introduces fans to
the original Robin Dick Grayson who's
played on the show by Brenton Thwaites
the series covers his journey to step
out from being under the shadow cast by
Batman and become his own hero Nightwing
soon after we are introduced to Karen
Walters Jason Todd and in season 3 we
are introduced to Tim Drake an
intelligent young man who figures out on
his own that Nightwing is Dick Grayson
Robin was prior to his death Jason Todd
and that Bruce Wayne is Batman
during season 3 like kirgo's Tim goes
through quite the transformative
experience as he is at one point shot by
scarecrow played by Vincent carteiser
and nearly dies during the finale of
season three we see that Tim is accepted
by the Titans and leaves with Dick and
most of the team to San Francisco and
the Titans Tower once more like cargo is
set to return as a recurring character
in season 4 of the show which has
already started production it's likely
Tim's training from dick or Bruce might
be a focus on the show's plot moving
forward it's impossible to know whether
we will see like Ergo again impossible
sequels to the Batman it seems unlikely
that the actor would play two different
robins and two different live-action
universes then again we do have three
different actors set to play three
different big screen versions of Batman
in the same year so anything's possible
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Batman are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]